[MUSIC]
My dad grew up in a small town in
Eastern India named Hazaribagh,
where life revolved around coal.
Schools, bridges, hospitals,
libraries were built over generations
directly by the coal industry.
Coal companies even provided
rights to movie theaters.
My grandfather worked here for
30 years as a coal mining engineer.
When it was time for
my dad to decide on his career,
there were now two options in
front of him, coal and now oil.
He picked the latter partly because
their offices had air conditioning.
If you've ever been to India over the
summer, you may understand that choice.
As a result of that simple decision,
my family's life transformed.
We moved from India to China to Texas.
All the while, I was privileged
enough to receive an elite education.
But despite that, when it was time for
me to decide on my career,
I also felt drawn towards energy issues.
How predictable and boring?
I wondered if I should distance myself
away from energy just to avoid doing what
two generations in my
family had already done.
Ultimately, I settled on clean energy,
telling myself,
this is different enough from
what my parents did, and
maybe I can still retain some
semblance of originality.
And I enjoyed it too, for
the first time in my career,
it felt as though I was connected to
a mission that was broader than myself.
But deep down,
something still didn't feel quite right.
As clean energy transition and
sustainability became mainstream
buzzwords, it seemed as though everyone
on my LinkedIn feed, including myself,
had suddenly taken up arms in some
sort of war of biblical proportions.
There was an epic battle being
waged against climate change and
every investment banker with a green
bond was a climate justice warrior.
Now I'm all for enthusiasm, but it
started to feel a little too convenient,
a little inauthentic and
frankly, a little hollow.
Personally, I felt ungrounded.
The more I tethered myself to this
grand ambition of climate change,
the more distant I felt from my roots and
family history.
But as I was working to
reconcile this personal dilemma,
I came across a broader and
much more important problem.
Amidst all the excitement about new,
clean energy technologies and innovations,
what was often never talked about were
the people actually on the ground.
I wondered, as the world moved away
from fossil fuels, what would happen
to communities like my dad's hometown
who depended on coal for everything?
Who is looking out for them?
Let's take a moment to consider the life
of an average coal mine worker in
a developing economy.
They have worked in the mines for
20 years,
they've developed hearing impairments
from being too close to blast sites.
They have respiratory illnesses from
direct exposure to coal ash day in and
day out.
But despite these extreme challenges,
this job is a blessing,
it is virtually the only thing that
separates his family from extreme poverty.
Now imagine what happens when nearby coal
plants in the surrounding area are shut.
He loses his job,
there's no other industry in town,
which means that the only two
options are to leave town or
try his hand as a daily wage laborer.
How tragic that the same person who
bore the brunt of all the environmental
harms of coal will now also bear the brunt
of the transition to clean energy.
As countries move away from fossil fuels,
millions in already vulnerable
communities will be put at serious risk.
Over 10 million people are dependent
on coal just in India, but
this is a problem for the world, China,
Indonesia, Australia, West Virginia.
All these places have
communities that are dependent.
But let me be clear, coal does need to go.
If the world has to come close to
meeting our climate change objectives,
we do need to phase out fossil
fuels over the next few decades.
But the way in which we manage this
transition could be the difference
between sustainable growth and
human catastrophe.
Now there are some who say that all
transitions have winners and losers,
it's been this way forever.
That might be true.
But the sheer magnitude
of the current energy
transition will be disruptive
like nothing we have ever seen.
And when lives are disrupted,
especially in developing economies,
the result is not just unemployment,
it's extreme poverty.
Now, I've also heard the argument
that there'll be new clean energy
jobs to make up for
the jobs that are lost in fossil fuels and
maybe even more jobs will be created
in the aggregate over the long term.
But human beings don't live in
the aggregate or over the long term.
They live in the here and now,
with all the struggles and
dependencies that have been
deepened over generations.
Some also say that it should be the
government's responsibility to take care
of those who are left behind so that the
private sector can focus on innovation and
technology.
But that's simply too convenient,
just relying on the government to
take care of social consequences is not
a strategy, it's a feel good exercise.
We need to move beyond wishful
thinking and think holistically about
how our energy transition cannot
just be clean, but also just.
Now, no two communities will
have the same solution.
For some, it could be a direct swap of
fossil jobs to clean energy jobs, for
many others, like my dad's hometown,
entirely new industries have to be
created, whether it's eco-tourism,
agriculture or construction.
But here's the deal,
investing in the communities that will
be left behind is not just ethical,
it's practical.
These same communities represent
much of the opposition to clean
energy legislation today.
So investing in them, supporting them, and
making sure they're not left
behind actually maximizes our
chances of achieving
the transition in the first place.
Now, there's a lot of work
that's left to be done, but
there are some important
early signs of progress.
For example,
the Just Transition Initiative and
the Climate Justice Alliance works with
companies all around the world to pursue
climate change mitigation but
also support marginalized communities,
all the way from South Africa to India.
But if we want to make a real dent in the
problem, our efforts have to be bolder and
broader, this is about a lot more than
just coal or any other energy source.
This is a while about how we think of
sustainability in the first place.
Sustainability must be broader than
just protecting the environment.
It must include protecting people,
especially those who are most at risk.
Now, companies and
governments are certainly important, but
I believe that you and
I have the most important role to play.
We know that Millennials and
Gen Ziers are the most likely to make
purchasing decisions based on
sustainable business practices.
So your pocketbook can
actually be a vote and
expression of solidarity with the voices
who are not yet at the table.
And as future business leaders,
it's our opportunity and
responsibility to ensure that those same
voices also belong in the boardroom.
So the next time you're stepping out for
your morning coffee, or
deciding what stocks to back on
Robin Hood, or preparing for
the next meeting in the boardroom,
push yourself to take that extra step.
Challenge yourself to do
a little extra research.
Ask yourself, how can I support
a world that is not just more clean,
but more just?
As we scramble to reduce
our carbon footprint,
what can I do for
those who will be left behind?
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]